-Welcome back, everybody!
I'm here with Pete Davidson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Thank you for doing
Random Instrument Challenge
with me.
-Oh, thanks for having me.
-I appreciate it, buddy.
-That was an experience
I'll never forget, for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-Before we talk about anything,
I wanted to ask you about this,
because I heard about this thing
that Alec Baldwin --
-Yeah.
-He asked you,
"How do you stay in shape?"
So he does 100 push-ups
and 100 sit-ups a day.
-Yeah.
-Now, have you heard that,
and is it true,
that you do 100 push-ups?
-No.
So, I was on set,
and Alec was hosting,
and it was a sketch
where I had to be shirtless
and, like, you know,
I guess, like, I'm a little bit
cut or whatever.
So he came up...
[ Laughter ]
There's no, like,
nice way to say that.
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
-I've never said that.
[ Laughter ]
-So he came up to me, and he
was like, "What do you do?"
And I didn't want to be rude
and say, like,
"I just still have metabolism."
[ Laughter and applause ]
So...
[ Laughter continues ]
I'm not in my mid-50s.
[ Laughter ]
I just wake up like this.
So to make him feel better,
I was like,
"Oh, man, I do 100 push-ups
and 100 sit-ups every day."
And he was like, "Got it."
[ Laughter ]
And then -- And then he got
the Trump gig.
And so I would see him
every week, and every time
we would run into each other
in the hall, he would be like,
"100 a day."
[ Laughter ]
And he started to do it,
and he lost like 100 pounds.
-Yeah, he looks fantastic.
-Yeah.
And it says it's all
'cause of me.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That is my favorite, dude.
I wanted to hear
about that story.
-Yeah.
-I wanted your opinion on this.
This is a very local story,
but it's a big story.
New York City is now legal.
They're legalizing weed.
-Yeah.
-What do you think about that?
Any thoughts?
And what --
-I think you can see it in my
eyes how happy I am.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's 12 years too late for me
and my police record,
but other than that...
[ Laughter ]
I think it's a great thing.
I think, like, you know,
finally.
It's a cool thing for the city.
-Yeah.
-Will anything change for you?
-Well, you're a giant pothead.
[ Laughter ]
No, I'm just kidding.
-I mean,
I'm just getting the contact.
I'm feeling something right now.
But I just find it interesting.
I don't know
how much will change, I guess.
-No.
For me, nothing.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
-But it is, like,
it's a great thing for,
you know, I think, for the city,
so I'm excited.
-Good.
How's everything going upstairs
on "Saturday Night Live?"
-Everything's great.
We got Carey Mulligan
and Kid Cudi this week,
which is awesome.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah.
-You've had a great season.
You have a lot of
good things happening
I want to talk to you about,
but earlier this year on "SNL,"
you had a great sketch.
This is you
and Timothée Chalamet
with our very own Questlove
in a sketch.
-Yeah.
-That was a big deal.
This is one the most
viral videos
to come from "SNL" this season.
Congrats on that.
-Thank you.
-What was it like
acting with Questlove?
-Oh, dude, total pro.
-Wow.
-Also -- Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's also, like, really cool
when someone who, like,
knows the show and watches the
show and is involved with it.
And it was just so fun
to work with him,
and he got to hit me,
which was cool.
Yeah.
-Yeah, I saw that part.
-I asked him if he would really
hit me and he said no.
-He told you to hit him
for real.
-Yeah.
-No.
-He's like, "I don't feel it.
Hit me for real."
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I thought it would be cool
for the sketch.
-You can't have Questlove
hit you on national television.
-Yeah, but, like, I don't know,
you can usually tell
when it's a fake hit.
I wanted him to punch me
in the face.
-Hey, can I get a go?
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, hey, hey, hey!
-Any time.
-It was just a sketch.
Come on.
[ Laughter ]
-It would be an honor.
-You have cool projects
coming up I got to talk about
'cause I'm excited about this --
"The Suicide Squad."
-Yes.
-The trailer came out,
and it broke a record
for like the most --
it was like 150 million people
saw this trailer.
And here's my man right here
from the trailer.
-Hell yeah.
That's right.
-Pete Davidson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Come on, now!
-That's your boy!
-Come on, now!
-Yeah.
-You play the character
of Blackguard.
-Yeah.
-Do you know anything
about this character going in,
or how did you get involved
with the movie?
-I love, you know,
superhero movies,
and I'm a huge James Gunn fan.
And I got a call
from James Gunn.
He was like, "There's this role
for you in the movie,
and you play a guy
named Richard Hertz."
I was like, "Dick 'Hurts'?
I'm in."
[ Laughter ]
-Ah, I didn't even --
-Yeah, that's his real name.
My character's name
is Dick Hertz.
-Yeah, there you go, yeah.
Wow.
-Yeah, and I was like,
"Dude, that's the greatest.
That's so awesome."
[ Laughter ]
And, yeah, he was nice enough
to let me be in it.
And, like, it's a thing
I still can't believe.
It's, like, ridiculous.
-How does this feel
when that comes out?
'Cause the world, globally,
saw that thing,
and they're all loving it
and so excited.
-Well, my family and friends,
like, it was the first time
they ever got super-excited
for anything I've ever done.
And I was like, "Thanks.
I just put a movie out in June."
-Yeah.
That was about --
-That was about me
and the family.
[ Laughter ]
-They didn't care about
that one.
They want to see this one.
-Yeah, but they were like,
"'Suicide Squad,'
the two seconds, man..."
[ Laughter ]
That two seconds
in the trailer, bro..."
-Dude, congrats.
-Thank you.
-I just want to say,
I don't know if I told you.
But "King of Staten Island,"
you crushed it, dude.
-Aww, thanks.
-It was great.
And there was some scenes
where -- yeah.
-And you're funny
in the whole thing.
-Thank you very much.
-And it's funny.
There's a couple scenes,
I'm like, "Go.
Go, Pete, go, man."
It was awesome.
It was really great.
I'm so happy for you.
I got talk about
the Audible original, too.
"The Hit Job" right here.
-Yes.
-Explain this to people.
What is this Audible podcast?
-It is an Audible original.
So it's like a movie or TV show
for your ears.
[ Laughter ]
Yes.
The person from Audible
backstage is, like, sweating.
-Yeah, they're gonna be like...
[ Laughter ]
-So it's pretty much a show with
Keke Palmer, as you can see.
-Yeah.
-And she gets a job at a company
that hires hit men to kill
the world's most dangerous men.
And, you know, it's fun,
and it's dark, and, like...
-Funny.
-Yeah, it's really funny.
-And if you're in it,
it's funny.
-It's funny, and you don't have
to see my face,
which I heard is a lot of
people's problem with me.
-No! What are you talking --
No, no.
-So you just get to just listen,
and it's really great.
And it comes out August --
August -- No, April 22nd.
[ Laughter ]
Yes, I'm almost done.
-That's good.
-And there's 12 episodes.
-We just love having you.
Pete Davidson, everybody.